[Musique]
bonsoir
nous sommes très contents aujourd'hui
car gros ours est tout à fait guéri et
se sent très bien on vous dit pas trop
je me sens bien
la vie est belle je me sens léger au
labo je manquais tomber mais fais
attention nounours tu n'es plus un
papillon si tu tombes tu vas te faire
très mal c'est vrai patron je ne suis
plus un papillon à l'on descend voir nos
deux petits amis ils t'attendent
sûrement avec impatience mais que fais
tu nounours je jette mon échelle pour
pardon patron j'ai rien jeter du tout
que je suis distrait ce pauvre nounours
le printemps lui à tourner la tête aux
propos aux op
vive le soli bouadma au port qui lui tu
sais bien que tu dois faire tes gars car
ils n'ont alors gens comme un mur à bâle
alphil ça te fera du bien bon cas
[Musique]
bonsoir mes enfants joly les thèmes à
paroles tucistes on pousse au petit
louis
il a plus tard brousse on ne sait pas
vrai j'en ai juste perdu quand tu n'as
pas dans mes propos et puis on peut pas
moi j'ai beau
j comme un putois l'eau à l'ombre
elle va vite repoussée 7 dans tous les
petits enfants changent de d'en haut et
où est-ce que tu l'a caché mais il faut
bien la cacher et quand la petite souris
la trouvera elle l'a progra et elle
mettra sa place une jolie pièce de
monnaie tout brillant oui mais à
condition qu'on ne suce pas son pouce
car c'est très vilain de sucer son pouce
les petits enfants le savent bien et moi
je ne sus jamais mon pouce machine
je suis jamais mon pouce oui mais toi
t'as pas mal au tas et puis toi tu m'a
toujours aidé dans ton et moi tentons
des draps les wallons les enfants
allaient à lons les enfants on va cacher
cette petite dent ou là tu mises petit
louis
tous
toi orvoine le joli 7 dandine où est ce
qu'on va la cacher ici ou là un petit
peu oui
la petite souris et le rappeur et
n'osera pas eu d'avis aggrave les
petites souris ça grimpe je vous le dis
sur la mettait dans les fleurs non les
enfants confiés là moi je connais une
bonne cachette je m'en occupe
wallace of holy les enfants petit louis
tu ne suce plutôt pouces 1
et toi tu rappelles tu ne mets plus les
doigts d'en tourner un c'est promis bon
tu oublies pas madame non soit
tranquille petit louis je m'en occupe
au revoir les enfants à demain
m
[Musique]
e
c'est toujours ce peut être bavard à te
voilà quand même lambin mais qu'est ce
que tu fabriques nounours la non non la
la
ce mieux patron j'ai caché là dans de
petits louis j'espère que la petite
souris la trouvera ah oui alors ne
faisons pas de bruit pour ne pas lui
faire peur en route nounours
bonne nuit les enfants c'est de beaux
rêves à demeure à demain
e
[Musique]